so obviously they'll continue continuing
the extensive searches for the missing
baby of constance Martin and Mark Gordon
after they were located in Brighton last
night
the pair were arrested in stamina
fillers at around 21 30 hours on Monday
the 27th of February after a member of
the public saw them in the shop
in hollingbury place
I can confirm that they were initially
arrested on suspicion of child neglect
I can now confirm
that they have been further arrested on
suspicion of gross negligence
manslaughter and that they remain in
custody at police stations in Sussex
the baby was not with them and we have
not found the baby at yet
the police helicopter sniffer dogs
thermal imaging cameras and drones are
being used to assist officers on the
ground we currently have over 200
officers from multiple units across the
Metropolitan Police and Sussex police
involved in the search
throughout this investigation our key
priority has been finding the baby
and we remain committed to that
there is a significant amount of police
search activity in Open Spaces to the
north of Brighton near to where the
couple were arrested last night
before the arrest the last known
sighting of the couple was in New Haven
on Wednesday the 8th
of January I am therefore appealing to
members of the public between Brighton
and New Haven to report
they may have seen some people sleeping
I'd also ask people living in these
areas to report any suspicious Behavior
equally if you are out walking in these
areas and you discover something
you think is pertinent to the
investigation please don't hesitate to
contact us
no matter how insignificant it may seem
support from the public is vital and it
is the support from the public that has
been key to date in this investigation
we have received a large number of phone
calls from members of the public drawing
the investigation
I would like to thank everyone who's
come forward with information
and especially the person who quickly
called the police last night after
spotting Constance and Mark
our colleagues from Sussex police were
on scene within minutes to make the
arrest
we are very grateful for the support
that they are providing
and any information that could assist I
ask you to ring 999 immediately
and I'll hand over to my colleague
thank you
so we are supporting the Metropolitan
Police on this extensive search
thanks to the vigilance of a member of
the public our officers were on scene
within minutes of the reporting sighting
and made arrests
an immediate search was launched
including the National Police Air
Service helicopter drones dog units and
every available officer and staff member
from across the force
these searches are ongoing and the
public can expect to see an increased
police presence in the area as well as a
dedicated response to any information
from the public
we acknowledge that there may be some
disruption to the people living and
working in the area and we thank those
people for their patience and
understanding at this time
I'd like to thank the local community
further for all the help they've given
us so far
we have an extensive search area and
will be in this community for some time
some people may want to know what they
can do to help
we just ask you to remain Vigilant and
please report anything of note to us if
you have any information that will
support the search please call 101 and
in an emergency please dial 999 we have
dedicated call handlers available to
talk with you thank you
so we're happy to take some questions if
anyone would like to start
TV
have you come to the arrest further
arrest on suspicion of gross necklace
so obviously the arrests occurred
obviously last night obviously just
after 9 30.
we've had significant periods of time in
the custody facility with both contents
and Mark at this time we have not
furthered that information which has now
obviously led to the position where we
feel that the risk is getting so great
that we now have to consider the
possibility that the baby has come to
harm and that will now be subject as
part of that investigation by the
officers involved have they admitted to
that
this time it's purely based on the fact
as part of the investigation strategy
but I will you know reiterate that we
still remain focused on a search and an
open land search to find the baby safe
and well they started cooperating at all
with earlier on they didn't they weren't
even revealing the gender of the baby
have they 've given any information at
all about that no we further no
information in relation to the gender of
the baby
um as part of the post arrestorce part
of the investigation at the moment
I I wouldn't be drawn on a time frame I
think whilst we still have hope that the
baby can be found safe and well we must
retain that hope and as you see the
number of officers we have deployed on
that open search however as time
progresses as the whether it is it is
closing tonight as it was last night in
terms of
the cold the coldness and the impact
that would have on a baby clearly the
risk is getting higher and we have to be
open to the fact that this may not end
in the way we would like but we need to
remain hateful and that is why over this
late turn today into the night and you
will still see the numbers of officers
deployed on that search for the very
reason of locating the baby
what do you think's brought them to
Brighton what sorry what do you think
has brought them to Brighton and have
you got any information which suggests
that they've been in touch with any
third party at all
no at this at this time obviously and I
think it's key into the previous
um
releases and in discussions we've had
with you with yourselves in the media is
you know we've seen from the 5th of
January when this incident occurred and
started in Manchester that they moved
very quickly from Manchester to
Liverpool to Essex throughout London
before obviously coming to Sussex and at
this time we have and didn't have as
part of all of that investigation posted
process uh information that was you know
brought us to reasons of location and it
will form part of the investigation now
obviously to date and will continue and
that would be part of that you know our
strategy to work out why and why they
came to Sussex and where they have been
in that intervening time as well and
before he was arrested it appears that
he was with a stick and there's been
some footage shared online of the pair
of them walking around can you confirm
that can you help us out with that we
are looking into that footage I can't
confirm it right now uh I hope to be
able to come back later with um
I've seen the footage and we are looking
into that footage um
that you know they both um obviously
were booked into custody and as part of
that process we would have and have
received the appropriate medical
assessments about that booking in
um period what they were actually saying
were they living rough within the
allotments were they actually on the
Downs where's your focus of the search
going so working hypothesis Still
Remains that
um we believe them to be and have been
in the open land and open areas that is
why our our focus and our search is as
where it is we are cognitive to the fact
that you know there are outbuildings is
a vast amount of land I've been my
colleague in around the the geography so
the the location as you know from being
here today uh is vast uh we're looking
at the sort of corridor uh between where
they were last cited and here of about
seven miles by 13 Mile sort of length in
duration so 91 square miles worth to be
searched we just encourage the public to
be vigilant if you see anything please
report it our dedicated officers are
working their way through that and I'll
Focus really remains at this time while
there is still some hope for finding
this young baby on doing so absolutely
abundantly camping equipment
at this time no got no further
information
no this time we haven't got any
information from the custody process
that's supporting the location or the
welfare of the baby just going back to
when they were arrested just going back
to the point when they were arrested a
couple of things quickly can you give us
a bit more detail about the member of
the public who reported it and how that
unfolded were they a shop worker did
they follow them up here a bit how did
that happen and also going back to that
footage it appears that
um Constance Martin may have been
wearing a puffer jacket and a dress and
Mark Gordon also in a puffer jacket and
a bag of Travelers again with a walking
stick what were they wearing when they
arrested and did he have the stick when
they arrested and what I can say around
the uh the arrest is it it was a
diligent member of the public who
observed them accessing a cash machine
and then further entering the shop and
they remained Vigilant bringing 999
which alerted Sussex police which saw a
response from the initial 999 call to
the arrest of about six minutes and that
obviously was also the movement of the
couple and just short of the location
where we are right now last question and
just a follow-on on their condition
during the arrest
is anything in their conditions
suggesting that they have been living
Outdoors for a sustained period of time
yeah I think you know we can quite happy
to confirm you know from from these
initial assessments that we have which
then links into our the rationale and
reason for the for the why we are doing
open land searches is because
um upon locating the couple and they're
resting the couple there is information
you know very much significant
intelligent information as part of that
arrest process that brings us to a
hypothesis that they have been and
spending a significant time Outdoors
um living uh in the in the countryside
and obviously the the Basta land that
you obviously have here in Sussex and my
apologies we'll do one more question and
then
there may be a possibility someone was
taking care of the baby on their behalf
is that sort of the possibility you are
entertaining we always have to keep our
open mind to the investigation it is a
reason why we did offer the 10 000 pound
reward and that ten thousand pound
reward
remains open because what we know is
that Constance and Mark did have a
substantial amount of cash this within
this investigation what we don't know is
drawing the movements how they come
across an individual that has taken pity
to the cause and through cash that's
available to them allowed them to seek
refuge in either a premises or
outbuildings and it's to those
individuals you know we say that that is
where the reward sits we have to keep
open-minded and it is one of the
hypotheses that we are working to
that point so I'm afraid I'm afraid no
more questions but we just want to leave
you with the statement that we thank you
for your time this afternoon we thank
the public for their support on this and
we want to work diligently to see
whether we can still find this baby at
this time so thank you very much
everyone